I was shocked you saw the first season
of the show this is gonna be you know
that on steroids it feels like an epic I
didn't breathe for the first 25 minutes
of the first episode I did not breathe I
just think it's gonna rock everyone my
name is June I was born I am free The
Handmaid's Tale is finally back it's
been an exciting season that is I think
dark creepier and more complex in the
first
what do fans need to know going into
season two yeah I need to know what
happened to see the woods and et has you
covered here's what you need to know
about season 2 straight from the cast
I had my ideas of what maybe would
happen but you have to sort of sift
through the first five ideas and then
land on where we went
is this what freedom looks like the
emmy-winning series it does pick up
where we left off
what was your number one question and
did you get your answer where she goes
when she gets in that band and yes I did
it so will you in the first 10 minutes
reminder Offred slash June is pregnant
with Nick's baby I'm trying to keep you
alive you know baby obviously now he's a
father divot to be
he's still very much caught up in his
romance with Alfred and there's a lot
against them and she's just been a part
of The Handmaid's rebellion I'm sorry an
idiot
she knew she had dropped the ball at the
end of season 1 and I think you'll see
what the measures taken to correct the
situation for that is is love the world
outside of gilead it will be explored we
are in the colony we come here we work
we die we go to the colonies which is
where on women are sent when they're not
good and it's it's terrifying it's
haunting it's also quite beautiful in a
way contaminated and I found that she
you know while she has lost some hope
she still had this sort of sense of
personal dignity and relationships will
be tested no one is ever completely
innocent and no one is ever completely
good or bad if you chewing that gum one
ounce of kindness she would never have
life this is weird juxtaposition between
trying to dominate and also loving women
with a powerful voice we can't explain
this away they will say that we're part
of the resistance that's the interesting
thing about Gailey edit but everyone is
trapped in a sense you know and it's
even Serina who's in a powerful
relationship she can't get out either
you know even if she wanted to no matter
what I'm I can't stop I wanted to know
how Luke and we're going to get on and
been thrown together everyone know how
that would work out some stuff goes down
in Canada which kind of puts them on a
part of adventure
[Music]
you had to sum it up with just one word
for that one word be resistance one word
can I swear oh hey hang in there there's
hope
[Music]